[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres
ils sont sept 7 candidats d'europe
écologie les verts à briguer un siège de
député dans les yvelines
nous ferons un point sur ces candidats
qui tentent de s'imposer sur le
territoire on continue notre série de la
semaine sur les différents sites
yvelinois retenues pour la candidature
de paris aux jo-2000 24 aujourd'hui gros
plan sur le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le complexe sportif pourrait accueillir
les épreuves de cyclisme sur piste
et puis direction le festival de cannes
où nous retrouverons trois étudiants de
l'institut de l'image et du son
d'elancourt leur court métrage tout ce
que j'ai a remporté un concours organisé
par la société europcar
nous ferons aussi un point sur les
acteurs de la région ile de france au
festival on débute ce journal avec de la
politique et plus précisément la course
législatives vendredi dernier europe
ecologie les verts a dévoilé ses
candidats pour les douze
circonscriptions dans les yvelines
qui sont ils quelles sont leurs axes de
campagne réponse dans ce reportage
camille lambert l'écologie grande
absente du débat présidentiel dans les
yvelines sept candidats d'europe
écologie les verts feront entendre leur
voix en faveur de l'environnement tous
impliqués dans des associations locales
ou en politique comme olivier paréja élu
municipal à guyancourt et à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
il est candidat pour la première
circonscription faire que chacun
retrouve une place digne donc avec le
partage du temps de travail par exemple
avec le fait d'avoir un logement décent
le fait que la pollution en ile de
france c'est quelque chose sur lequel il
faut absolument travailler
nous sommes dans des zones proches des
zones agricoles là aussi il ya quelque
chose à faire
préserver la ruralité un des axes de
campagne de patricia charton elle est
candidate dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines
face à david douillet une libanisation à
grande à grand train qui vient manger
les terres agricoles
on le voit sur plaisir on le voit on le
voit aussi sur quoi si on sait que le
psg a acheté les terres de dupont si par
exemple la ruralité quelque chose de
très important pour les gens qui sont
venus habiter là outre enjeu pour le
parti la nomination de nicolas hulot au
ministère de la transition écologique
la présence d'europe écologie les verts
à l'assemblée permettrait d'appuyer ses
projets une vision écologiste à
l'assemblée c'est effectivement mettre
l'accent sur un certain nombre de
problématiques environnementales
mais c'est également
mettre l'accent sur une certaine vision
de l'économie une vision de l'économie
qui est à mon sens c'est celle du futur
à savoir l'économie qualitative mais
j'ai l'impression que mise à part les
écologistes personne ne comprend
cette nouvelle façon dont la société va
s'orienter dans certaines
circonscriptions europe ecologie les
verts a fait des alliances avec les
partis communistes et socialistes c'est
le cas dans les 2e et 3e
circonscriptions avec tanguy ruelle ans
et nicolas eu pour la 10e
circonscription david jutier
représentera l'écologie dans le fief de
jean frédéric poisson dans la 11e
aucun candidat n'a été investi à noter
une réunion publique autour de
l'éducation est organisée ce soir à
20h30 salle du vieux marché à jouy en
josas à l'initiative jean-noël barrot
candidat de la république en marche dans
la 2e circonscription des yvelines
une autre réunion publique est à prévoir
avec didier baichère candidat lui aussi
du parti des manuels macron pour la
première circonscription c'est demain à
20 heures 10 rue des mouettes à montigny
le bretonneux
on referme cette page politique la fête
des lauréats organisée par le réseau
entreprendre se dérouler le 17 mai
dernier au palais des congrès à
versailles
le but de l'événement récompense et 20
jeunes pousses du monde de l'entreprise
dans les yvelines
ils étaient cinq cents 500 chefs
d'entreprise pour mettre à l'honneur une
vingtaine de lauréats
le but de l'événement est de récompenser
des jeunes entreprises et surtout de les
mettre en lumière pour créer du lien une
initiative que daniel herrero parrain de
l'événement et ancien joueur du rugby
quinze de france approuve le principe
général du fonctionnement de ce club
d'entreprises c'est d'être ensemble
entre
des gens qui ont déjà de l'expérience
qu'ils ont les rudesses du monde digérer
qui ont les capacités a pas baissé les
yeux dans les tempêtes
s'il y en a 80 de la main il crée dû
lire leur créer du lien après après le
lien et la différence d'intensité il a
différentes chaleurs et c'est pour cette
raison que la société e dts une société
d'ingénierie automobile a décidé de
faire partie du réseau entreprendre base
est attrapé créé il ya un an
l'entreprise a besoin de tisser des
liens avec le monde de l'entreprise pour
s'imposer sur le bassin tente un premier
parce que j'ai effectivement d'être
lancé mais dans un second temps réseau
entreprendre ça ça vous sort de
l'isolation d'un chef d'entreprise ça
vous permet d'avoir une famille une
appartenance alors un groupe
et puis surtout ça nous permet de
collaborer sur d'autres projets ensemble
donc il ya il ya plein d'aspects
positifs à elle pas réseau entreprendre
d'ailleurs la société e dts a fini parmi
les 20 lauréats de l'événement son
business plan a séduit le jury
la chef d'entreprise est donc reparti
avec 30000 euros une somme qui lui
permettra de recruter des salades
et notre série de la semaine est dédiée
aux différents sites yvelinois retenues
pour la candidature de paris aux jo-2000
24 après la colline des long courriers
air gros plan aujourd'hui sur le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
le complexe sportif pourrait accueillir
les épreuves de cyclisme sur piste
les détails avec michael et demi d'euros
le vélodrome national de 50 ans neeve il
est déjà prêt à accueillir les jeux
olympiques seul projet francilien avoir
survécu à la candidature de paris 2012
la structure a officiellement été
inauguré en janvier 2014
depuis cette date le site s'éroder en
organisant les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
une expérience qui a impressionné le cio
pendant son passage
bien sûr ça à lèves le doute sur sur
toutes les interrogations qu'on pourrait
avoir la l'équipement il est là il a été
testé et l'a accueilli déjà la plus
grandes échéances internationales avec
les championnats du monde donc je pense
que tout ça c'est forcément des
garanties pour le cio pour accueillir
les supporters pendant les jo 5000
places ont été construites de la
structure on a une proximité avec la
piste voilà puisque au delà de la
balustrade les le public est juste là il
peut être un maître finalement des
coureurs qui passent avec des vitesses
élevées un des coureurs qui atteignent
70 quasiment 80 km heure sur les
épreuves de sprint
donc voilà toute cette ambiance et ce
show très spectaculaire sur la piste pas
fait que le public généralement et et
soutien et supporter grandement ses
athlètes
le spectacle se passe également sous la
piste les 250 m pour 8 de large sont
entretenus régulièrement pour mettre les
athlètes dans les meilleures conditions
ses références et donc on voit à quel
niveau mais puisque par exemple en cas
de chute on peut être amené à remplacer
des tasseaux de bois sur lesquels les
pour un rôle par le dessous donc voilà
on peut essayer de se repérer là on voit
que bien sûr on est dans une courbe donc
dans un des deux virages de la piste une
charpente en bois qui est déjà marquée
par les performances des pistards
tricolore sur la piste du vélodrome
nationale
là on à grégory baugé multiples
champions du monde qui était aux
derniers aux derniers jeux olympiques
quentin lafargue médaillé de bronze ici
aux championnats du monde sur piste à la
on à michael d'almeida qui est multiple
médaillé olympique
la nouvelle génération rêve sans doute
d'imiter leurs aînés en inscrivant leur
nom sur les poutres du vélodrome après
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
la dédicace sera peut être programmé
pour 2024
on prend à présent la direction du
festival de cannes
les festivités ont débuté la semaine
dernière et ont vu défiler plusieurs
stars du 7ème art et parmi elles la
région ile de france
elle soutient 14 films sélectionnés
camille lambert les braqueurs moi je
trouve ça con que la méprise
j'aimerais vous l'auriez de pleurer
pleurs lors des deux révérés lors des
deux marques à 4-4 et de l'eau font pas
trop ça grotesque louis garrel dans la
peau de jean luc godard monstres du
cinéma français un biopic attendus sur
la croisette en compétition officielle
au festival de cannes
il fait partie des 14 films soutenus par
la région ile de france et s'est même
l'aide la plus importante
445 1000 euros
l'île de france fait aussi la part belle
au documentaire pas moins de sept
financer en 2016 dont celui de raymond
depardon 12 jours traite des personnes
hospitalisées en psychiatrie
il est présenté à cannes en sélection
officielle l'an dernier la région un
dédié un budget de 20 millions d'euros
cinéma et à l'audiovisuel un
investissement récompensé à cannes en
2016 avec le prix caméra d'or pour
divine oui c'est comme les chiens se
sont toutes à toronto 10 août à s'ouvrir
davantage à compeyre tu as ta peur et tu
écris pas un souci mais avant la
compétition le cinéma c'est avant tout
un échange avec spectateurs cet été pour
la première fois la région organise des
projections gratuites en plein air sur
quatre îles de loisirs dans les yvelines
rendez-vous les 28 et 29 juillet à lille
et loisirs du val de seine je vous
dirais du bout des choses
il y à la région ile de france mais pas
seulement
trois étudiants de l'institut de l'image
et du son d'elancourt eu la chance de se
rendre sur la croisette
leur court métrage tout ce que j'ai a
remporté en co organisé par la société
europcar dont le siège est d'ailleurs à
voisins le bretonneux regardait
[Musique]
je vous donne tout ce que j'ai
l'histoire de notre court métrage en
fait il s'agit de maele 35 ans c'est une
femme qui va acheter une voiture à un
particulier donc l'oeil de chevaux va
devoir se rendra à saint-raphaël
donc le soir donc on le découvre
pourquoi dans le court métrage à la fin
et il va lui arriver tout un tas de
péripéties donc des rencontres pas mal
de problèmes des problèmes à résoudre
très rapidement
écoutez c'est ridicule mettez vos
cercles dans mon corps que je vous
ramène chez vous vous savez ma ptite
dame
je suis pas très à l'aise en voiture
mais je connais pas comme une sauvage à
les imiter
ça me fait plaisir c'est pas vous
attendez que marc est promue c'est pas
ta voiture
l'image qu'on avait du festival de
cannes c'est que c'est quelque chose
d'unique c'est un rêve pour tous les
cinéastes qui débute soit en étudiant ou
un professionnel très très belle elle va
tomber regarder ses talons ils sont
immenses jamais on n'aurait imaginé y
aller un jour et là on a n'a pu réaliser
notre rêve quelque part des marchés
voilà on a la pression
c'est ça qui est assez incroyable on a
vingt enfin 8 19 20 et voilà enfin on
est déjà ici à monter les marches
ce qui est fou quand même c'est que est
tellement de gens qui voudraient y être
et puis nous on a cette chance de
pouvoir y toucher du doigt et et se dire
que aux caisses accessible et en
réalisant des films peut-être qu'on
pourrait réussir à venir ici quoi voilà
puis c'est clair que ça fait sur le cv
c'est quand même vachement plus cool de
qu'on a fait la montée des marchés et
puis et puis même si une expérience
qu'ont ça fait rêver quoi et son hangar
des étoiles dans les yeux de tous les
jours jusqu'à jusqu'à la prochaine fois
alors pour aussi à son festival la
septième édition courants d'art a eu
lieu la semaine dernière organisée tous
les deux ans par l'école d'arts
plastiques et l'école de danse de la
ville
l'événement rassemble plusieurs
disciplines artistiques à la ferme du
mousseau écouter marie lavaud
co-organisatrice de l'événement au micro
de nicolas baudry c'est de créer un
festival vraiment transdisciplinaire
c'est-à-dire de rencontres entre les
disciplines mais pas seulement de faire
se produire des disciplines les unes à
côté des autres mais véritablement de
faire travailler un danseur en arts
plastiques de faire travailler un poète
en peinture de faire travailler un
comédien en danse et l'objectif c'est
d'ouvrir le plus possible les
imaginaires des élèves des écoles de
danse et d'arts plastiques puisque
deuxième spécificité du festival la
pratique commune vraiment commune entre
amateurs artistes amateurs et artistes
professionnels
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de nous
avoir suivis et surtout bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]